this video is brought to you by me I
made a t-shirt and a whole bunch of
other things you can buy them in the
description if you want k byee within
the scope of one piece I think water 7
is perfect when I began my journey
through the extensive catalogue of arcs
and sagas that make up the story off one
piece I knew that I'd be greeted by
engaging lovable characters I knew I
would be taken on long and complex
stories and I knew it was going to be
great but I could have never predicted
what was going to happen in this arc and
the emotional character driven
storytelling that made this for me a
brave intelligent and important story
specifically for Schilling jump to show
its reader base I had no idea things
were going to develop like this but boy
am I happy that they did and I have so
much to say about it and praise it for
today we explore the exuberance the
enchanting and the excruciating arc that
left me in an emotional tizzy with my
jaw firmly on the floor I'm totally not
Marc and these are my first impressions
off thoughts on and review for the most
unexpected arc in one piece of story for
me and one of if not my favorite
installment so far this is the one piece
masterclass water 7
[Music]
world-building is a term that i've
thrown around a lot since I started
covering this story and when someone
repeats the same term again and again
and again it starts to lose its meaning
one of my favorite aspects of Dragon
Ball was the incorporation of snake way
and the afterlife for Goku to explore it
not only added a much-needed sense of
levity to the circumstances of that
story at the time but it also provided
further insight to mechanics and lore
that would be called upon as it
continued and that's sort of what world
building is in a nutshell in one piece
it's so painfully obvious that Oda
adores this world that he's created and
he fills it with everything his
imagination can see fitting in there and
this isn't just for fun but to establish
and to give us the audience the
impression that this is a real breathing
world with real technology real
political structures and geography and
this is all in an effort to create
believable real characters for us to
enjoy within this world and let me tell
you these characters in this arc felt
got wrenchingly real and I mean that in
the best possible of ways but more on
that later
once again this story is incredibly
impressive and how it establishes what
the situation's are it gives the
audience a goal to aim for at the very
beginning which changes as the story
evolves and the separate storylines that
establish themselves early on
independent of each other start to
intertwine until they clash in what I
can only describe as the single most
compelling set of chapters I have ever
in my life
read through but before I drool over how
ludicrously perfect this arc is I want
to impress upon you the importance of
what Oda did to establish this arc in
the first place because it's brilliant
two major points of contention within
the arc come from one singular piece of
information and goal that's established
and built upon at the very beginning
they need a ship right because the merry
go is struggling with damages from the
single piece of info we understand that
this arc will center around the
recruitment of a new crew mate which in
and of itself is exciting but the means
with which our weaves this tale is not
only compelling but stupidly effective
so let's take a look the goal as I
mentioned before is established early on
and even before the hit land on water 7
we are introduced to this drunk old
woman that is quite literally what
nightmares would look like if they took
human form but she does give the crew a
letter to pass on to mr. iceberg and we
see some really interesting technology
in the form of a seafaring train - but
once again this is far from the last bit
of new tech we see and when it comes to
world building once we arrive on water
702 opens the floodgates exploring this
beautiful new area he's introduced
inspired by Venice but with clear and
obvious odor twists on the theme with
its wildlife its culture and most
impressively how it implements and makes
use of its abundant supply of water
fashioning waterways and even elevator
systems which is all explained to us
among many other things because much
like Skype here with its Dyle technology
informing the culture that it's built
upon water sevens architecture and
culture is of course built around the
fact that it has so much water
incorporated there's an infectious
attention to detail here that makes me
just want to leap onto the page and
explore these worlds for myself and not
to mention talk to these inhabitants and
that's not only the sign of a great
writer but it's also the sign of a
writer who loves the world that he's
creating so much so that I'm certain no
one loves this world more than Oda and
it shows but part of what made this one
so exciting and interesting to watch was
that right from the get-go as they
arrived on water 7 the gang split up
into four separate groups luffy sapa
nami traveled to the shipbuilding area
to suss out the situation regarding
repairs and with their top priority
being that they need a new ship right -
we also are looking for that chopper and
robin are out seeing the area Sanji is
shopping for groceries and Zorro is
guarding the ship all super
straightforward stuff and no conflict
just yet Luffy even meets the town's
famous shipwrights who are pretty big
celebrities in the town and there's this
really cool character wearing a hat that
has the weirdest nose I've ever seen but
some of the coolest character design -
needless to say things are going too
smoothly and so it's time to inject some
conflict and boy do we get conflict from
the most unlikely of places in this arc
as this cool ship right assassin's
creed's his way across the city to check
on the merry go wrong ends up needing to
defend the ship from some evil looters
called the Frankie family which she does
so with ease but that's not the only bit
of conflict here this strange masked
someone walks by Robin whispers
something into her ear and she starts to
walk away with it
losing chopper in the crowd and it's
these chapters that offer setup to later
events that most people might not see as
highlights but one aspect that stuck out
to me was a particular chapter that
covered Sanji said
fairs in it we see the shipwright all
tiring and parkouring his way across the
rooftops to see the merry go and we also
see Robin being guided away this is all
from Sandy's point of view and we don't
really ever see that in manga this felt
so great to me as it makes the city of
water seven feel like a real place with
all of these things happening in real
time rather than a series of separate
scenes where characters act with it it's
a subtle inclusion but it made the world
feel that much more immersive for me and
these paths crossing in front of Sanji
set a series of things in motion the
Robyn's story thread and the merry go
story thread but perhaps the most
interesting plot thread the sob story
thread before Luffy ozawa Nami fractured
away from the main group something oda
made sure to express throughout his time
writing the stories of alabasta saga sky
pious saga and even this saga has been
how much love and care Youssef gives to
the ship he's always the one repairing
it despite not really knowing how to
fully and he often makes mention of how
much the ship itself means to him it was
a gift from someone he deeply deeply
cares for and so it makes complete sense
that that's where his passion is life
and how the next section is paced is
honestly brilliant having already been
foreshadowed prior with Zorro the
Frankie family in an effort to steal the
money the straw hats have in their
possession and fully intend on spending
on repairs NAB Yousef and the cases he
was carrying as Nami and Luffy wonder
where he's vanished off to the awesomely
designed assassin's creed's ship bright
guy reappears to give his analysis on
the state of their ship and it's
fundamentally beyond repair it's
completely unsalvageable apparently and
despite Luffy's questioning and thinking
of alternatives eventually he's forced
to come to the conclusion that he needs
to buy a new one for his crew this is
when they noticed that Asif is missing
only to find him beaten and bloodied in
the middle of the street he panicked Lee
confesses that they took all the money
and that he tried to stop them but
couldn't because he was too weak he
resents his efforts because to him he
now believes that he might have just
destroyed their chances of fixing the
ship but obviously we know at this point
that the ship is regrettably beyond
repairs nami leaves him against the wall
before bounding towards luffy to inform
him of aha
as luffy gathers the crew fills him in
on the situation and the plan of action
who's up once again staggers and makes
his way back to the gangs lookout and
unfortunately gets beaten to within an
inch of his life and as the straw hats
walk up towards the building they once
again fine Deus up barely hanging on
at this moment I'm like I need Luffy to
bring balance to the world right now or
I'm going to explode
and boy does he do just that and along
with the combined efforts of the rest of
the straw hats totally demolished their
hideout and all the henchmen that
committed this atrocity towards OSA and
it is awesome this particular scene had
a lot in common for me with Nami x'
moment from arlen park luffy avenging a
crew member and friend and this one is
incredibly cathartic too but something
is hanging in the air a certain piece of
news that won't go over well with who's
up this next section of the story is
without an ounce of sarcasm jest or
hyperbole perfect to me the motivating
factors the character the dialogue oh
the dialogue and not to mention the
physical conflict that ensues this
section made me feel a way I don't think
I've ever felt while consuming manga or
anime at this point in the story with
the Frankie gang having been dealt with
despite not retrieving the money Luffy
is satisfied with how things went and is
ready to move on with things
but boosts up is the only one unaware of
the Mary goes current state and this
uncomfortable tension hanging in the air
one Sue's up asks why Luffy is so dead
set on going with a new ship at this
point in the conflict I was incredibly
nervous I hadn't mentioned during my
alabasta arc video that the one aspect I
really didn't like about it was the
conversation Koza has with the king that
conversation to me felt stilted or
natural and contrived because instead of
speaking like real people with specific
things and specific ideas with specific
responses they delivered vague response
after vague response all because the
story needed for these two to have the
wrong idea of each other in order for
the story to work and this is something
that's in almost every single TV show
movie or whatever I honestly hate it but
that's not what happens in this scene
instead the conversation that takes
place felt more real than some of the
conversations I hear on the street it
felt so raw in this scene there's very
little action really it's ball 2
dialogue and it had me gripped with
every single page turn and that's how
you know these characters work this
scene didn't have to make up a forced
reason for them to fight like Zora and
Luffy did and whisky peak this didn't
have a vague conversation to create fake
tension like the King had with Koza in
alabasta these two characters spoke and
acted like real people they explained
themselves and their characters informed
the conclusions that came to and the
actions they took in response to those
conclusions this is the best character
writing I've ever seen in manga it's
pretty much perfect it feels like a real
argument between real people because we
know all the same information the
characters do we understand the
characters immediately and know that
they are acting like we would expect
them to if this was taking place in the
real world I just adore the moment when
Luffy completely loses it almost
verbalizing something before Sanji cuts
him off with a kick and for Luffy to
immediately regret saying that
afterwards felt even more real
conversations like this happen in real
life
and they ruin relationships there are
real consequences to what you say or
don't say in these cases and now
disillusioned and feeling alienated by
Luffy Musab challenges Luffy to a fight
the winner of which gets the ship at
this point the relationship between the
two has been ruptured this is intensely
interesting now and what follows is
equally as good continuing the tension
of the prior only this time focusing on
the action and strategy surrounding you
stop fighting Luffy and once again it's
amazing this is easily my favorite fight
in the entire series without question
and if that's an unpopular opinion I
swear to god I'm gonna lose faith in
humanity I've never been so invested
conflict and uncertain how a fight was
going to end and I don't just mean the
physical fight this is a battle of
prides and outlooks and the best part is
that I can see and understand the points
of view of both characters the merry go
is as much a crew made as the rest of
them to loose up it holds even more
sentimental value due to where it came
from and now it feels as though Luffy is
completely turning his back on a friend
in need - Oh sup Luffy is completely in
the wrong here but on the flip side
Luffy is faced with an incredibly
difficult decision - he doesn't want to
lose the merry go either but he has to
be responsible for the lives of his crew
both characters are in very difficult
circumstances with very difficult things
to talk about and it's it
to Asians like this that make for the
best scenes and the circumstances that
ensued during this battle are fantastic
uncharacteristically unafraid in
defiance juice' takes advantage of the
deep understanding he has a Bluth be
totally unloading everything has on the
rubber man including many twists and
turns taking even me as a reader
off-guard juxtaposing how terrible he
look right after the attack by the
Frankie family with how confident and
sure of himself he is in this instance
however as the fight pushes forward and
further on Lucia begins to wane and
that's when it starts to get back to
watch with some fantastic symbolism in
the rain making the ship look as though
it were crying Luffy deals the finishing
blow to us up and walks away declaring
that he can have the ship if he wants it
it's tragically sad Luffy has been up
until this point steadfast in his orders
and decisions but for a split second in
a moment he's trying to keep private
pushing his hat over his face we see him
begin to break he's human at the end of
the day and he just can't afford to be
unsure if he's the captain echoed in a
quote from Zorro that is perfectly in
character for him to say if you waver
who can we trust
what an amazing sequence the psychology
at play here is what made these
characters work so incredibly well for
me the comparatively small altercation
between a captain and his crew mate more
than any other anime for me has explored
in surprising detail what it means to be
a leader and what the cost of leadership
sometimes needs to be and everything
that the crew says or does not say in
these scenes is informed by their
characters also this isn't just the ESOP
and Luffy episodes it's about everyone
else - chopper has to grapple with the
morality of helping you sub after the
battle
Sanji recognizes a Fault in what luffy
was about to do and say and kicks him he
doesn't wanted to hold on to regret like
he had to at SEF and so put it into it
as soon as he saw where it was going
Nami in this scene wants everything to
return to normal to her she's losing her
only family and only sense of stability
she's ever really had and she's
struggling with it Zoro recognizes that
this is something that needs to happen
also every single thing in this scene is
believable tragic and more important
than anything else it's important to
realize that it achieves this intense a
scene because everything in it makes
sense and before I move on
one thing I haven't ever really
mentioned yet about the manga that I
absolutely love is that at the beginning
of each volume it lists the name of
characters and factions contained within
each installment and for the first time
since he joined the crew Musa is listed
on his own outside of the straw hats
crew I'm not gonna lie this broke my
heart but it's a really nice little
detail and clever use of space to do
this little bit of storytelling
not to mention reinforcing the
consequences of a scene that was utterly
spectacular in commemoration of my
journey through the high seas of one
piece I figured it's about time the TNM
crew got their very own official pirate
flag design made by the community for
the community this minimalist design is
based on my very own avatar with an
obvious one-piece twist I think it looks
awesome and it's available in t-shirts
hoodies critics sweaters phone covers
and all that good stuff all in the
description down below this design will
only be available while supplies last so
if you like the design or want to
support the channel comp yourself some
new style and join the pirate crew today
a weapon to surpass metal gear
[Music]
the mansion heist I think something one
piece does that always make sure I'm
invested is that it utilizes
well-established characters like ooh
stop and now Robert in this instance as
both a motivating force for the
characters and as an incentive for me
the reader to keep on reading it's a
testament to how wonderfully structured
and realized this straw hat crew really
is if two of them having an argument can
yield such a visceral reaction from me I
was very eager to see what they did with
Nico Robin next and I wasn't
disappointed I glanced over this earlier
but while at the shipyard Luffy and Nami
pass on the letter to mr. iceberg given
to them by Kokoro apparently he's the
mayor of the town and seems like a
likable stand-up dude well I didn't know
then but even here they were setting up
groundwork for a major plot point thread
to happen in the future now if you cast
your minds back to the sky pier video I
made mention of nico robin and my
feelings towards her being that of
mistrust i felt as though there was
something she wasn't letting on she felt
very removed from the group and so when
the cp9 masked figure came out of the
shadows to lure her away i suspected
immediately naturally that something was
up but i had no idea she'd turn out to
be an official member of a secret
government group that at this moment is
tasked with retrieving something of
vital importance from the mayor of water
7 but the thing is we don't actually see
any of this and how it's all revealed
felt so much more like a mystery
thriller to me that I actually loved it
all the while who's up in Luffy were
duking it out cp9 and the rest of them
had infiltrated and made an attempt on
mr. icebergs life and as Luffy and the
gang wake up from their night sleep in
the end they are met with conflict after
conflict their first conflict comes from
the leader of the Frankie family
[Music]
franki himself who is a cyborg which
pretty much throws out all of my sense
of what the current level of tech in
this world is capable of anyway he's
charismatic and fun but he stoled all
the money and spent it all to which when
I honestly read that at first a little
part of me died in sight
but what really got me was what happens
next iceberg wakes up after being shot
several times only to point the finger
at the straw hat crew nico robin
apparently was responsible for the
attempt on his life and now they are all
wanted by the city okay so max who's up
is now estranged Robin is a cutthroat
for some government organization all the
straw hats are being persecuted for this
action on behalf of the entire city and
to put the icing on the cake a massive
tidal surge is expected to hit the city
tonight
this current set of predicaments felt so
incredible to read through tensions were
high and there was a mystery in the air
why was Robin doing this and furthermore
what I love is that despite all of these
major story beats hitting hard code it
doesn't just let loose up be forgotten
until he's needed again not even in the
slightest fully in character he has
chopper and Sanji covertly let loose up
know what's up regarding a massive tidal
surge that's to be expected tonight
without hurting his pride there are so
many little things like this that are
being juggled in this arc that Odin not
only keeps track of but also delivers
compelling scene after compelling scene
with he didn't need to have this scene
with Sanjay and chopper he could have
just had a noose up make some random
mention in the next scene that he
appears in that he saw that the tide was
changing but he instead made a character
choice he asked himself what would these
characters do sanjay and chopper cared
deeply about him and thus of course they
would look out for their friend it not
only adds context Hawaii houssam moves
location later but reinforces the entire
theme of the story in that arc
friendship and loyalty and really that's
been the theme from the very beginning
how much trust and loyalty should be
honored and how their dynamics mix
together in volatile ways should you
trust your captain when he breaks what
you perceived to be his loyalty to a
ship should you rely on your crew when
you're faced with a massive underworld
government organization both robbing a
new sob have believable
motivations guiding their choices in
this arc and it's so well done I can't
help but sit back and marvel and in
keeping with this theme of loyalty it
comes to our attention that Robin
planned to pin this on them all along be
trained them using them pretty much as a
scapegoat to allow her and the rest of
the cp9 crew to infiltrate the building
the next night and boy do they
after alerting us up Sanji decides to go
walker on the city without saying why to
chopper who then goes to reconvene with
the rest of the straw hats just what I
thought this story was lacking some
twist and surprise to catch me off guard
as it happens the secretary and three of
the town's famous sip rights including
that really cool Assassin's Creed long
Square nose guy were all part of cp9 the
entire time to be honest I really wasn't
expecting it to be them at all when I
first saw that one of them was wearing a
feathery sort of outfit it reminded me
of the ensemble doflamingo wore if you
were to ask me before this reveal I
would have placed all of my bets on him
being involved in some shape or form but
he's not and it gets even better with
this guy here who had been up until this
point using a bird to speak from him it
turns out that he can speak for himself
and uses this as an advantage to try and
take the blue prints off of Paulie and
on top of all of that we finally start
to get some answers surrounding the
story of Nico robbing the panic lifts
and what the pluton is that crocodile
was after in the first place it turns
out it's a battleship a massive weapon
that if wielded could bring about
destruction on a worldwide scale so
needless to say it makes sense as to why
he keeps those private and I also really
really like the reasoning why just
destroying them isn't an option for them
either it's important to make sure that
if something does rise up the pluton
could be its equalizer these blueprints
for the pluton the iceberg was in
possession of are a wonderful little
plot point in the background that I'm
guessing will be an overarching plot
thread for many more arcs to come I'm
also happy we finally got some
information about Robins backstory an
orphan shot from a specific people that
almost died out she's the last one and
therefore the only one with the ability
to read the Ponte glyphs making her in
the eyes of the government dangerous if
she isn't working for them to bring the
weapon to their possession this is my
first taste of proper large-scale world
politics playing a role in the one piece
story and it made it feel all the more
intense because of it the scope has
never been larger no longer is this a
self-contained arc
no no no this time it's concerning
itself with all the information and
breadcrumbs left behind over the last
three sagas this arc feels enormous and
this is all just built up this whole
Nico Robin situation is entirely set up
to be the catch-22 the conflict of this
arc and it serves the purpose
tremendously well acting in a similar
fashion to Nami in the our long par [ __ ]
Robin denounces her allegiance to the
straw hats straight to their faces when
confronted by them in the act
once again reinforcing the themes of
loyalty and friendship by having Robin
seemingly cast such things to the side
however after they discovered the
blueprints to the ship have been hidden
elsewhere she is told to take her leave
to the last train to Ennis lobby before
the enormous tide arrives at midnight
well this also adds a massive amount
attention to the occasion as Anna's
Lobby is a place of no return apparently
there's also a time limit involved now
with the tide and to add tension on top
of tension the cp9 agents former ship
rights take out both Zorro and Luffy
with just absurd East's sending them
flying across the city but they don't
kill them despite having the power to do
so which was interesting to me ever
since they revealed their true
intentions they had been quite literally
unstoppable in terms of physicality
mastering certain techniques and
practices that allow them to pretty much
have the power of gods and their
fingertips which makes for some gross
and truly unsettling imagery which all
serves the big fight scene where Zorro
Nami and Luffy all Korra the shipwrights
but are unable to do anything to them
the lead ship right pretty much
transforms into a giant leopard swatting
away both Zora and Luffy without so much
as a second thought and with Robin
helping these guys it's at honestly an
incredibly complicated situation to get
a hold of but wouldn't you know it Oda
has a reason for that - as it happens
Robin isn't bad and doesn't feel
uncaring towards them at all in fact she
loves them her only condition on working
for cp9 was that her friends would be
spared and spared they were in this arc
everything is slowly falling into place
and what makes it even more interesting
is that mr. icebergs confidant the
person he entrusted the pluton
blueprints to was none other then
yes Frankie now with time running out
Robin boarding the train the two best
fighters out of commission and the gang
completely separated it's times like
this I not only reflect on the story and
how it got here but how much I love
these damn characters I mean there's
this spectacular scene where Frankie is
just chilling and reminiscing with usopp
about the merry go how this ship was
staying together for them because it
loved them and how he needs to accept
the fate of that ship too switching from
an antagonistic force to a mean good guy
character is an incredibly difficult
thing to pull off but he does so by
being so damn charismatic regalia Sam
was an explanation for the vision he saw
in the jungles of sky PA that it was in
fact the spirit of the ship
struggling to stay together for them
because it really truly cared about them
which not only humanized the ship but
also allows us to be thankful towards
Frankie for sharing that information so
kind-hearted Lee to us up who's clearly
struggling with it through this we
learned that Frankie is actually a
really chill and honest responsible guy
obviously the word honest is him
quotations there and what's more is that
we get a fantastically compelling
backstory for him where and we learned
that he's the one that has the
blueprints he grew up under the man who
made the seafaring train and that guy
was the one who made gol D Roger ship
and what's more is that the antagonist
from the government in that flashback
that killed his father figure Tom is now
behind the cp9 situation a tennis lobby
see what I mean about all of these
seemingly unrelated plot threads
developing in real time and clashing
with each other in natural ways well it
just keeps happening
the cp9 bossed into their workshop and
kidnap both Frankie a noose up but not
before sending the merry go crashing to
the sea below which not only makes me
want these guys to be eviscerated from
existence but now they're on the trade
with Robin and what's more is that they
are heading to a place called in his
lobby where in addition to no one ever
really returning from their alive is
also the place where Frankie's father
Tom was sent
that's where Robins being sent to also I
just love this story that all converged
right at the end but not before leaving
our heroes in dire straits and it's
moments like this that make me think God
it's so difficult to choose a favorite
among these characters they're all so
perfectly realized and enjoyable in
their own different ways but I think
when I turn the page and realize that
son
gee all this time had been waiting
outside the train for Robin to arrive
and leaving I might have fallen in love
with him there and then it's still
between him and Nusa but I just adore
Sanjay he's the perfect blend of flawed
cool and he absolutely drives the plot
for in ways few other characters do in
this series the Train the Train sequence
in this arc might be the best set-piece
idea in all of one piece I've
experienced so far it's straightforward
to understand in that Sanjay needs to
make his way through the train cars to
reach Robin who stopped in Frankie
there's a clear goal for Luffy and the
rest of the crew to pursue them in order
to give Sanji backup there's a built-in
time limit as they are about to arrive
at in its Lobby shortly the gang is
separated the villains are together and
the motivations are clear save Robin
save us up and save Frankie before the
blueprints fall into the wrong hands and
boy was I rooting for Sanji during this
one the setup is honestly great - with
each subsequent car in the Train filled
with more and more dangerous folks but
once angie reaches OSAP and Frankie who
were held towards the back of the Train
where he initially hit the strategies
implemented our clever and satisfying to
watch with the majority of the bad guys
lured to the back of the Train before
being cut loose entirely and what I love
this isn't just because as a clever plan
on behalf of Sanji it's that it also
highlights why this particular action
sequence is so interesting and fun in
the first place as luffy's or onami
choppered the water seven shipwrights
and the Frankie family are following in
another train behind them and because
there's only one train track it means
that anything that is caught loose will
eventually have to be dealt with by
Luffy and the gang as they chase after
their friends honestly it's an
incredibly creative sequence and the
best part is still to come
you see once Sanji saved Frankie and
Aesop despite wanting to help out Robin
after understanding the situation Musab
still felt tremendous shame and so
instead of running away he decided to
disguise himself as so quickly eager
[Music]
with the English translation being
sniper King but I'm just gonna call him
Sokka King I think this is really clever
as it sort of comes out of nowhere in
the story but all the motivations and
materials for this decision are there
naturally we understand that new sub
wouldn't want to face the team after
what he had said and done but what I
found really subtle but great is that
earlier in the train car fight
Sanji makes a passing remark about all
the people he just took out only having
costumes and masks on them and nothing
else of value which he says directly to
you some so not only does who's up have
the motivation to create this disguise
in the first place but he also knew
where to get the materials for it which
oda didn't need to do but it just shows
the insane level this man operates on
and speaking of details remember when i
mentioned when you saw left the crew
after his fight with luffy that oda took
him out of the manga character breakdown
straw hat group well now he took how
loose off entirely and replaced them
with saga king which is hilarious I just
adore stuff like that and it just
reinforces the notion that this is a
story that rewards you for paying
attention to the little details I've
never been more satisfied as a reader as
I have been while reading one piece and
its core water 7 and I think one piece
works as well as it does because of the
ridiculous detailing attention oda has
given to its world without all of this
polish these characters wouldn't feel
nearly as believable and to me the
show's greatest strengths are its
characters and how these characters
bounce off the themes of a given arc for
instance the motivations you saw had to
save the merry co are the same
motivations that Luffy has to save them
he is putting the lives of his crew at
risk braving treacherous waters heading
towards a place that certainly won't be
a cakewalk all to be there for his
friends and it's parallels like that
that create this incredible feeling
while reading and by the time Frankie
and Sanjay buy use up enough time to sit
down and talk with Robin in the front
car alone in once again highlights the
strengths of this series it doesn't need
world-ending stakes to be captivating or
fantastical we just need to care about
these wonderful characters and when a
sob says have faith in Luffy - Robin I
honestly shed a tear
because that line encompasses what this
entire arc has been about boosts up
called Luffy's judgment into question
fault him over it and now deeply regrets
it
he sees Robin making this same mistake
and is trying to help her see reason
it's incredibly purposeful writing and
it's bloody fantastic this series sucks
you in and forms an incredible
connection with you you always want to
know are these characters going to be
okay and I think that's what makes this
one of the best stories I've ever read
through and what's more is that it's
brought me closer to so many wonderful
new talented people in the community
last week I held the competition to see
who could draw the best avatar for me on
YouTube and Twitter and the standard was
just ridiculously high but by the end
this wonderful person won and now this
will be my new Oda style avatar while I
cover the high seas of one piece but
with that said and with the train now
closing in and arriving at in his Lobby
I have sincerely no idea what to expect
or what will happen I adore the
characters of Frankie I think he's
incredibly distinct and given the amount
of backstory in detail this character
has received I will be very surprised if
he didn't turn out to be the shipwright
of the straw hats when all is said and
done next week I will be covering and
his Lobby and the post and his lovely
material so look forward to that but
that'll do it for this video as always
I've been totally nut mark I'll see you
all next week and thank you so much for
watching